[تصفيق]
العودة إلى الجيش إلى الجيش
بسببي وأنا هنا بسببك لذلك لدينا
شيء ،
شكرًا لك يا رجل ، روح عظيمة ،
كل شيء هنا نذهب إلى
خطوات الفيلم ،
شكرًا لك يا رفاق
أولاً وقبل كل شيء مرتاحًا ، دعنا نحصل
على  وقت
ممتع ، دعنا نقضي وقتًا ممتعًا ، والسبب الآخر
لوجودي هنا اليوم هو أن أشكرك شخصيًا وأن أشكرك شخصيًا
وكل فرد من أفراد الخدمة في جميع أنحاء هذه
المنطقة على القضاء على الخلافة
الإقليمية لداعش
في العراق وسوريا
منذ عامين عندما أصبحت رئيسًا.
مجموعة مهيمنة
للغاية كانوا مسيطرين للغاية
اليوم ، لم يعدوا مهيمنين بعد الآن ، لقد
نظرت إلى خريطة
وقبل عامين كان هناك الكثير من اللون الأحمر في
جميع أنحاء تلك الخريطة ولكن الآن لديك
بضع نقاط
صغيرة وهذا يحدث بسرعة كبيرة  هذا
يحدث بسرعة كبيرة ،
سترى أنني أريد فقط أن أقول عملًا رائعًا
وسنراقب تنظيم الدولة
عن كثب ،
لقد جئنا إلى الأسد لمشاركة
امتناننا الأبدي لكل ما تفعله
للحفاظ على
سلامة أمريكا  ong and free
شكرا جزيلا لك
نعم شكرا جزيلا لك